POOR, MIDDLE-CLASS, PEOPLE ON
FIXED INCOME ACT.
REMEMBER IT WAS UNDER
DONALD TRUMP OR 1.4 INFLATION.
ENERGY INDEPENDENT, EXPORTER OF
ENERGY, OUR BORDER WERE SECURE.
SAFETY AND SECURITY WE HAD AT
HOME AND ABROAD AS WE WERE
RESPECTED AS A COUNTRY.
DONALD TRUMP ACCOMPLISH ALL OF
THAT WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
DEALING WITH CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
ONE HOAX AFTER ANOTHER, ONE LIE
AFTER ANOTHER, ONE PHONY
INVESTIGATION AFTER ANOTHER.
NOW ALL OF IT UNDONE BY
JOE BIDEN IN 18 SHORT MONTHS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SUCCESSORS ARE
CHRONICLED IN A NEW BOOK BY
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR AND
SON-IN-LAW JARED KUSHNER.
HE JOINS US NOW.
HE'S THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK IN
BOOKSTORES ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
OF COURSE Amazon.com.
"BREAKING HISTORY: A WHITE HOUSE
MEMOIR."
THE AMAZING THING, YOU ARE A
PART OF HISTORY.
MOST PEOPLE WILL NEVILLE REALLY
TRULY UNDERSTAND WHAT LIFE IS
REALLY LIKE IN THAT HOUSE AND
WHAT GOES ON BEHIND THE SCENES.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
ANY OBJECTIVE OBSERVATION OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY WAS A
CONSEQUENTIAL PRESIDENCY.
A D.C. AFTER 18 MONTHS WORK AND
HAPPEN IF YOU ABANDON THE
POLICIES THAT YOUR FATHER-IN-LAW
INSTITUTED IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT WAS IT ABOUT HIM.
WHAT DID YOU SEE ABOUT HIM THAT
MADE HIM DIFFERENT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, SEAN, IT'S
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
IT WAS A GREAT HONOR TO SERVE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
RESPONSIBILITY VERY SERIOUSLY TO
FIGHT FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND KEEP HIS PROMISES.
YOU WERE SPEAKING EARLIER ABOUT
ALL THE DIFFERENT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT HE WAS ABLE
TO HAVE ECONOMICALLY.
THOSE WEREN'T AN ACCIDENT.
THE INFLATION THAT'S HAPPENED,
THE RISING GAS PRICES.
ALL OF THAT HAPPENED UNDER THE
GUISE OF THE INVESTIGATIONS AND
THE ATTACKS.
I WRITE EXTENSIVELY IN THE BOOK,
IT REALLY IS, EVERYONE WHO HAS
READ IT HAS HAD IT'S A
FAST-PACED READ BECAUSE I WEAVE
TOGETHER ALL THE EFFORTS TRY TO
PUSH FORWARD IN THE DIFFERENT
POLICIES AND SIMULTANEOUSLY
DEALING WITH THESE FALSE
VISITATIONS.
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE BASED ON
CRAZY ACCUSATIONS, WHETHER IT
WAS A RUSSIAN HOAX.
TRYING TO IMPEACH HIM FOR
INVESTIGATING CORRUPTION IN THE
UKRAINE.
SERIOUS ACCUSATIONS.
ONE STORY I TELL US HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEGOTIATED A
DEAL BETWEEN SAUDI ARABIA AND
RUSSIA IN ORDER SAVE OUR OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY WHICH NOW THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION IS
HAMPERED WHICH COULD BE BRINGING
DOWN THE PRICE OF GAS IN THE
COUNTRY VERY QUICKLY IF ALLOWED
TO.
INTENSE NEGOTIATION PAIR
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT ALONG WITH
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
HE GOT ALONG WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
GOT ALONG WITH PRESIDENT XI.
DIDN'T MEAN HE DIDN'T HAVE TOUGH
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM BUT I
REALLY GO THROUGH THE WAY HE
DEALT WITH THAT WHICH IS HOW HE
KEPT THE WORLD PEACEFUL, ALL OF
THE CRITICS THAT WERE LYING
ABOUT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
FOR FOUR YEARS, THEY WERE SAYING
THAT IF TRUMP WAS ELECTED, HE
WOULD LEAD TO WORLD WAR III.
WE HAD SIX PIECE DEALS DURING
TRUMP'S TIME AND THE WORLD WAS A
VERY, VERY SAFE PLACE.
GOING THROUGH ALL THAT
EXTENSIVELY.
>> Sean: HATED IT WHILE BEING
INVESTIGATED THREE YEARS ON
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION THAT
NEVER HAPPENED.
HE DID IT DURING AN IMPEACHMENT.
ALL THIS HAPPEN.
AND THEN COVID HIT.
THAT THROUGH THE WORLD
UPSIDE DOWN.
HOW DID HE DO IT WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY HAVING TO DEAL
WITH ALL OF THAT STRESS THAT
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE CRUSHED A
MILLION OTHER PEOPLE?
>> IF YOU WOULD ASK THAT, HE
WOULD SAY, DO I HAVE A CHOICE?
HE WAS ELECTED.
HAD A BIG RESPONSIBILITY.
HE WAS VERY, VERY HARD AND WE
ARE VERY, VERY GRATEFUL.
AT NIGHT I WOULD TURN ON YOUR
SHOW AND I WOULD SEE YOURSELF,
GREGG JARRETT, SOLOMON,
SARA CARTER GOING OFF AND
BASICALLY SAYING ALL THIS STUFF
IS DEBUNKED.
I WOULD FLIP OVER TO MSNBC AND I
WOULD SEE THEM SAYING THAT THEY
ARE RIGHT ON THE HEELS, THEY ARE
ABOUT TO GET THESE GUYS.
BUT WE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
HE REALLY HAD TO BLOCK IT OFF
AND FOCUS ON THE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO DO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS VERY
FOCUSED.
ONE OF THE EFFORTS THAT I WORKED
ON AND THAT I DETAIL IN THE BOOK
WAS THE EFFORTS TO TRY TO BRING
PEACE BETWEEN ISRAEL AND THE
ARAB COUNTRIES.
THAT IS SOMETHING THE
CONVENTIONAL THINKING WAS THAT
IT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS AN OUTSIDER.
HE BROUGHT A BUSINESSMAN'S
APPROACH TO WASHINGTON.
BUSINESSMAN A RESULTS DRIVEN,
UNLIKE POLITICIANS WHO GENERALLY
WANT TO PROCESS.
THERE ARE SOME GREAT POLITICIANS
TOO BUT I WRITE ABOUT HOW AN
OUTSIDER WITHOUT A LOT OF
POLITICAL EXTREMES AND A TEAM
CAME IN AND WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
RESULTS THAT POLITICAL CAREER
PEOPLE WERE NOT ABLE TO ACHIEVE.
>> Sean: A TWO-PART QUESTION.
ONE SPECULATION ON YOUR PART.
MAYBE YOU DO KNOW SOMETHING WE
DON'T KNOW.
DO YOU THINK THAT HE IS GOING TO
RUN?
WHEN YOU FACTOR IN ALL YOUR
FAMILY WENT THROUGH VERY TALKING
ABOUT DON JR. AND ERIC AND LAURA
AND IVANKA AND THE WHOLE FAMILY,
WHEN YOU FACTOR ALL THAT IN, DO
YOU WANT HIM TO, WOULD YOU WANT
TO GO THROUGH THAT AGAIN?
STILL CONTINUES FOR A LOT OF THE
FAMILY.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK FOR HIM.
OBVIOUSLY HE'S VERY BOTHERED BY
WHAT HE IS SEEING HAPPENING IN
THE COUNTRY.
DID A GREAT JOB KEEPING OUR
ECONOMY STRONG, KEEPING OUR
WORLD SAFE AND REALLY FIGHTING
FOR AMERICAN INDUSTRY.
I THINK THAT HE KNOWS HE CAN FIX
IT VERY QUICKLY BUT IT'S EVENT
HOLE.
-- IT WAS A BIG TOLL ON THE
ENTIRE FAMILY.
THE COST OF SERVICE IN THE
ATTACKS WAS VERY SMALL RELATIVE
TO THE IMPACT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION WERE ABLE TO MAKE
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
ONE THING WE WORKED ON THAT WE
WERE -- VERY SUPPORTIVE,
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
HELPING PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES.
SOCIETY AND TRAINING AND JOB
SKILLS THEY DON'T COMMIT CRIMES
IN THE FUTURE.
THOSE PEOPLE WERE GIVEN A NEW
LEASE ON LIFE.
THE PARDONS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ABLE TO HELP
GIVE SECOND CHANCES.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THAT, IT
REALLY PUTS ALL THE PAIN AND THE
STUFF IN CONTEXT.
FOR ME, WRITING THE BOOK, I
ALWAYS LIKE TO LOOK FORWARD, NOT
BACKWARDS.
IT REALLY WAS A REMINDER OF THAT
BRUTAL FIRST YEAR WHEN WE HAD A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE TRYING
TO FIND THEIR WAY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
BEING ACCUSED OF COLLUDING WITH
RUSSIA WHICH WAS A CRAZY NOTION.
I WOULD SAY MOST DAYS I COULDN'T
COLLUDE ON THE CAMPAIGN WITH
DONALD AND WE COULDN'T COLLUDE
WITH THE FIELD TEAM IN IOWA IF
THEY SAID WE PULLED OFF THIS
ELABORATE SCHEME.
THE SAME PEOPLE PUSHING THIS
FALSE NARRATIVE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE CONTINUOUSLY ATTACKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
A LOT OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
FIGHTING JUST TO FIGHT THE
MIDDLE-CLASS SINNERS GIVE THEM
JOBS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO KEEP
OUR COUNTRY SAFE.
>> Sean: IT IS CALLED
"BREAKING HISTORY PRINGLES WITH
BOOKSTORES EVERYWHERE,
Amazon.com.
IF YOU WANT A SIGNED COPY,
Jared KushnerBooks.com.
I LEARNED A